switzerland's been in the news a lot
lately but what you might not know is
that right now Geneva's playing host to
the cell and international delivery or
sihh it's the most elegant trade show
you've never heard of we're here at the
25th annual sihh where the 13 watch
brands owned by swiss luxury
conglomerate rees-mogg along with three
high-end independent brands are showing
off their latest where's this is going
to set the tone for what wristwatches
will be like in 2015 there's everything
from more affordably priced sport and
dress watches that are simple all the
way up to insane creations that sell for
six and seven figures now the opulence
doesn't stop there to make sure that the
thousands of retailers collectors and
journalists almost forget they're
actually at a trade show reach Mount
really pulls out all the stops instead
of having to eat a takeout sandwich on
the floor for your lunch you can waltz
up the bar in order glass of champagne
and maybe some foie gras he's like the
swag isn't going to be a branded tote
bag or notebook it's going to be a
tablet or maybe a pair of Beats
headphones and the women Manning the
booths aren't wearing bikinis they're
wearing ball gowns those giant floral
dresses by this point you're probably
wondering why this is a trade show after
all people are actually doing business
but it to make sure that when you go
home and you think of these brands all
you can think of is luxury